How much more work would we have to do to turn our course projects
into something more like the web browsers we use everyday?
That is a nice question, and it's great to see students enthusiastic about extending the course project.
To get the key ideas across in the amount of time given,
we restricted attention in the course project to building a static web browser
like the sort of web browser you'd see on an electronic book reader
not particularly interactive, more concerns with downloading the web page and rendering it.
Let say though that we wanted to work on the project in our spare time and extend it
to become something a little more interactive.
If you're interested in that, I would encourage you to look at two old-styled web browsers,
Elinks and Mosaic, the precursor to Netscape or Firefox.
Elinks is an old text-based web browser.
Mosaic was one of the first visual web browsers.
Take a look at those and see the sorts of user interface options that they offer
to get an idea for what the bare minimum is for working web browser.
Let say though that we want to do it together.
In my mind, the first step would be to add the ability to have the user click on links.
We can already read in a web page. We can already render it out to a nice image.
Let's say, though, that we didn't worry about back buttons.
We're not worrying about bookmarks. No cookies.
Nothing fun like that. No foreign input.
We just want the user to be able to navigate around the web by clicking on links. How do we do it?
Well, right now our web browser is more of a batch processor.
You give an input to web page, and it produces the image and then it's done.
We want to add a little loop at the bottom that said
"Wait for user input. Wait for the user to click on the screen."
And let's imagine that through our GLE library or our graphics library
or through talking to the operating system or the windowing system,
we would receive some sort of notification whenever the user clicks in our window
and probably we get information like the X and Y coordinate of the mouse click
and whether or not it was a left or right click.
So we need to build up some sort of mapping from locations on the screen
to whether or not they correspond to href tags, links, the text displayed underneath them,
and we could do that while we were displaying the text on the screen.
If it's mostly images up here but then suddenly there is a link in the middle,
we want to remember, by the way about half way down the page, if the user clicks there,
it's a link, and we should know where to go next.
How do we know where to go next? That's just the href argument from that particular tag.
We already got that information at the lecture level.
We passed it to the parser, and we have it when we're interpreting.
We just stored in some sort of mapping off to the side.
Let's imagine that the user clicks. We check our little page to link mapping.
If the user is clicking in the margins or in the white space off to the side, we don't do anything.
But if the user is clicking in an area corresponding to a link, we fetch the value of the target location.
We say "Oh, it's something like http.google.com.index.html."
And we open up a network connection in order to fetch that web page.
If you took CS101 at Udacity, you may remember how to do that.
But if not, it does not take that long to pick it up.
And ultimately, we'd end up getting out a new string, a new file,
corresponding to the contents of that web page,
" Welcome to my web page", that sort of thing.
Then we just call ourselves again and render that new web page and display it on the screen
and then refresh our little mapping off to the side that maps screen coordinates to links.
And if we have this kind of power, then the user could click and navigate their way through the web
and then maybe eventually we want to add things like back button,
which would just require us to store lists, even lists of strings, of places the user had visited previously.
You can imagine starting to add abilities like clicking to navigate through the web,
going backwards, going forwards again to the framework that we've already set up.
And it would be pretty much as simple as adding a controlled loop
to the bottom of our existing batch web browser.
Now, let me give an idea of something a little more complicated under the hood
The graphics library that we are using to lay out text actually does a pretty good job of--
if you're saying a lot of words, "Welcome to my web page,"
eventually will reach the end of the screen, and it will wrap over to the next line.
Just like the word processor or a normal web browser.
You might wonder, how do I do that?
If I know the pages 18 inches wide, and I have a lot of text, and I know how big the font is.
It's a 12 point font all of the letters to this wide.
How do I figure out how many words to put on the first line?
How many words to put on the second line? That sort of thing.
That problem is called the word wrapping problem
or perhaps more formerly the minimum ruggedness word wrapping problem.
And it turns out that the human eye prefers column layouts that are not rugged on the side.
You don't want it to be over or under--that kind of thing.
Instead you want nice, even columns like a newspaper
or like a magazine article that looks more pleasing to the eye.
Well, in an incredible surprise move, it turns out that we can solve this problem using--
guess it--dynamic programming, memoization.
There is a mathematical equation you can write down
that sort of penalizes you for not having smooth columns
and then we can try a bunch of different layouts--which words I put on which lines--
and just memorize their "badness" values, how ugly they would look to the human eye.
And at the end of the day, we just take the one that looks the least ugly.
And it turns out that that's actually how professional typesetting pieces of software
like LaTeX or Microsoft Word solved this problem.
We want to do some of those things under the hood to make our output look good,
and we want to add support for things like clicking and following mouse clicks to navigate the web.
But ultimately, we are pretty much there with having a web browser
that similar to some of the earliest historical web browsers like ELinks and Mosaic.